the NTSB still investigating after our
Guardian flights aircraft headed to Salt
Lake City crashed near Stagecoach
killing all five on board Friday agency
says the aircraft started to break apart
mid-air after just about 14 minutes it's
recovered now all the pieces that fell
off the plane less than a mile from the
runway it is looking into weather
weather was a factor
weather conditions icing was reported
and moderate turbulence in the area
then dsb says the weather was considered
normal for the planes to take off and
the plane involved was able to fly in
similar conditions says the decision to
fly though was ultimately between the
operator and the pilot now